following the russian invasion of
ukraine in late february many nato
members including the us germany and
poland have pledged support in the form
of money 800 million
600 danish crowns 300 million pounds and
weapons canada will be sending heavy
artillery
and in addition to aid some in the
western military alliance are also
boosting their own defenses
germany pulled out all the stops they're
buying heavy cargo military helicopters
they're going to modernize the armed
forces across the board those
immediately bordering ukraine i'm
thinking romania here and poland as well
they're talking about tanks they're
talking very specifically about
anti-missile systems so as russia
unleashes new threats raising concerns
that the war could escalate outside of
ukraine here's how some nato countries
are looking to upgrade their military
capabilities
one major step to strengthen the west's
ability to deter moscow was announced by
germany chancellor olaf schultz said the
country would boost military spending
above 2 percent of gdp and invest the
equivalent of 113 billion dollars in
weaponry
this graph illustrates that spike in
germany's defense spending
they're buying f-35s
that's the sort of the the most modern
uh
jet fighter warplane produced by the
united states and and many if not most
of the nato members are using it at the
moment the aircraft is popular with nato
countries because of its ability to
evade radar detection its aligned edges
contribute to that ability
it can also carry weapons internally or
externally including long-range
precision missiles depending on the
environment it can reach a speed of mach
1.6 and has an extended range of more
than 1 350 miles with internal fuel
the f-35s will replace aging tornado
aircraft in germany's arsenal
many countries in western europe
including germany reduced their military
capabilities after the cold war
i think lessons learned from ukraine uh
and the invasion was
uh that countries are now looking at
where to strategically uh stockpile
weapons and
ensuring that they have the correct
capabilities for the threat
as countries such as germany shift their
defense priorities in the east of europe
nations have been preparing for a
potential conflict for longer you know
for many decades for years the the
eastern
flank of nato countries like poland
countries like estonia or lithuania and
in the baltics have been
acutely aware of of the aggression
potential of vladimir putin's regime and
they have been warning
their western peers
analysts say they've seen poland's
defense budget sustained growth over the
last eight years following russia's
annexation of crimea in 2014
prior to the latest invasion of ukraine
warsaw began negotiations to buy 250
abrams tanks and other military vehicles
in the wake of the war poland signed a
4.75 billion dollar deal and wants to
accelerate the delivery of the weapons
they have big advantages over the aging
soviet-built tanks that poland already
operates uh
the most important being that is that
they're less vulnerable
the abrams m1a2 scp-v3 is a modernized
version of the abram's main battle tank
it's fitted with armor on its hull and
turret designed to protect against
threats from explosives the tank can be
hinged with reactive armor and slat
armor and it can be fitted with a signal
jammer to counter radio-activated ieds
you've seen huge tank losses by russian
forces
in ukraine the abrams is just a
different design and very simply it's
it's less vulnerable to the kind of
anti-tank weapons you've seen deployed
by ukrainian forces in addition to
spending on new tanks poland is sending
some of its older t-72 models to ukraine
which has been requesting weapons
assistance since the war began in late
february
ultimately countries can only donate
what
uh would still enable them to have
the the spectrum capabilities that they
need for their own security analysts say
countries such as poland are using new
spending proposals to enhance their
military capabilities while sending
older stock to keeve there wasn't that
commensurate increase in spending
then the donations would potentially
create a gap
as some nations try to bolster defenses
and increase military budgets amid the
ukraine conflict the u.s weapons
industry could benefit
the us is by far the the biggest spender
and weapons in the world and also the
biggest exporter so it's to be expected
that a lot of the arms being talked
about by european countries will come
from there but supply chain issues have
made it difficult for some u.s companies
to keep up with demand and larger
weapons could take years to be delivered
in part because of lengthy contract
negotiations
with this uptick in spending that we're
seeing in a few countries faster way of
achieving uh more lethal capabilities is
through weapons and enhancements and
upgrades to existing platforms
you